[Applaus]
wenn man es zusammen zählt schon
ziemlich heftig was die neue regierung
alles erbt so ein praktikums beginn
wünscht man echt kein die deutschen
corona zahlen explodieren weiter vor
sich hin schon ohne neue afrika variante
man gibt's ja mal eine pause leute jetzt
haben die usa sogar eine klare
reisewarnung für uns ausgesprochen ja
hier germany reise sie dort nicht hin
schade ich hätte es mir so gern machen
geguckt wirklich ja
gerade im inland soll es viele schöne
ecken geben aber zu spät olaf scholz
will einen ständigen krisenstab in
seinem kanzleramt einrichten nachdem er
in sachen corona über wochen so
unsichtbar war dass man sich schon
gefragt hat lebt denn der alte holzmichl
noch ja
ansonsten diskutiert seiner ampel immer
noch eine impfpflicht für pflegeberufe
kommt vielleicht ab januar und hofft
dass zweig noch überraschend die wende
bringt oder das boostern die berühmte
dritte spritze gegen den nachlassenden
impfschutz ganz wichtig ja und
nein impft durchbrüche sind kein
argument gegen schimpfen es sind die
ungeimpften die unsere intensivstation
gerade an den rand des kollaps bringen
und darüber hinaus umso ärgerlicher
diese aktuellen bilder aus hamburg an
sie es gesehen die menschen wollen ihren
booster und die schlange geht bis
hannover
man musste so lange anstehen in dieser
schlange wurden kinder geboren und
eingeschult meine dann
kann man das nicht anders organisieren
anderswo werden impflinge wieder
weggeschickt weil der impfstoff alle ist
warum werden wir von allem immer
überrascht in dieser krise kann man sie
nicht auf irgendwas mal vorbereiten
sowie die österreicher diese krone im
straße in der österreichischen befindet
sich in dem bordell van palast hier
können sich alle bürger gegen korona
impfen lassen auch frauen und kinder die
hier normalerweise keinen zutritt haben
warum nämlich
wieder den fun palast
von van kann leider keine rede mehr sein
auch deutschland schlittert sehenden
auges richtung lockdown für alle ja
natürlich machen wir uns nichts vor in
sachsen und bayern erleben wir ja schon
die vorstufe und das ist halt die strafe
für den wahlkampf im sommer denn da
wollten politiker erst recht keine
unpopulären entscheidungen treffen
todesursache wahlkampf hätte das gedacht
so richtig bitter ist dass wenn wir
rechtzeitig in großem stil gebucht hat
hätten vielleicht hätte das denn
lockdown erspart stattdessen haben uns
einlullen lassen zb von diesem spot des
gesundheitsministeriums
steht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ende juli produziert steht so noch auf
der seite von denen man möchte heulen
ich behaupte spätestens in drei wochen
kann der sparen das hier auf seine seite
packen
hallo
kneipe zu keine freunde sehen
dafür fucking spaziere ich
kurz hier gleich im strahl
hallo
meine war er ist ständig rot
multipack tier bananen brot ich halte
das nicht mehr aus
[Musik]
es ist wieder noch downside
zu 2 es ist weder noch da sein
nicht aber wirklich der letzte
da fällt mir ein jetzt nicht im
heute-show fanshop für ihren nächsten
lockdown dass jens spahn schrei kissen
hier ich probier's mal aus moment
schon jetzt mir besser ja
die große diskussion die firma gerade
die große diskussion brauchen wir die
allgemeine impfpflicht
spannende schwierige frage
manche verfassungsrechtler sagen
impfpflicht für alle kann man machen
denn der artikel 2 des grundgesetzes
garantiert zwar die körperliche
unversehrtheit verlangt aber auch den
schutz des lebens anderer ist schwierig
also ich sag mal ich finde wenn man als
letztes mittel bußgelder gegen
ungeimpfte verhängt dann aber bitte
exponentiell das heißt für ungeimpfte
zeit in der ersten woche nur einen euro
strafe in den nächsten zwei
übernächste vier bedeutet nach 21 wochen
bis ostern werden wir bei einer wochen
strafe von einer million
48.500 76 euro
ich meine das gar nicht heimlich
verstehen sie so wird man nicht einfach
bestraft sondern lernt auch noch
spielerisch was exponentielles wachstum
ist aber
vielleicht brauchen wir das auch gar
nicht weil die einsicht 12 die
impfbereitschaft von alleine streikt es
gibt ja auch ermutigende beispiele hier
zum beispiel die fans von fortuna
düsseldorf neulich beim auswärtsspiel in
dresden
[Applaus]
chapeau
ich hätte jetzt war auch nein ich hätte
das nie gedacht ich hätte das nie
gedacht dass ich das als bvb fan sagen
muss aber fortuna düsseldorf hat
offenbar die kreativsten fans
danach haben sie noch folgendes gesungen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
o
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der fußball die stimme der vernunft
also abgesehen vom halben fc bayern
natürlich
und vom trainerstab von werder bremen
wird ist eine andere geschichte ja was
macht in diesen düsteren tagen wo
nachrichten gucken gar keinen spaß mehr
macht sonst noch hoffnung vielleicht die
kommende frührente von ihren spaß denn
alter was dieser mann hinterlässt wie
soll man das zusammenfassen noch
nutzerin ruck noch letzten august hat er
gesagt es wird in keinem fall einen lock
down für ungeimpfte geben dieses
permanente ausschließen von maßnahmen
die dann doch kommen das zermürbt die
menschen und dann wundert man sich über
politikverdrossenheit und das vielleicht
auch mal die an die adresse der
querdenker da draußen hinter der
deutschen corona politik steckt kein
großer geheimplan es gibt überhaupt
keinen plan
nicht wahr einen kleinen hier jens spahn
wohlgemerkt letzten sonntag nun ich habe
tatsächlich vor einem schweren herbst
und winter gewarnt
die deutsche impfkampagne ist noch
erfolgreicher als bisher gedacht das
gibt uns zusätzliche sicherheit für
herbst und winter
wozu braucht man überhaupt noch satire
frage
auch die niedergelassenen ärztinnen und
ärzte sind stinksauer auf den man nicht
übersehen mehr oder weniger alleine die
impfkampagne stemmen jetzt hat er ihn
noch eine eigens nest gelegt mit seiner
katastrophen kommunikation haben sie
auch gelesen timo piontek wird
rationiert nimmt gefälligst moderner
denn das wird sonst schlecht
wie soll
diese wie so ein kellner hatte sagt wir
stellen sie bitte die scholle die
stimmte schon
das heißt das marketing genie hat es
tatsächlich geschafft ein top produkt
wie moderner schlecht zu reden wenn er
nicht er abgewählt wäre man müsste ihn
wirklich bei ebay einstellen es ist es
ist wirklich so so und ärzte leider
bietet leute ärzte wie doktor christian
ehring baden das jetzt aus wir schalten
wir live rüber in seine praxis herr dr
-ing wie sauer sind sie auf ihren sparen
herr welke ich sage es ihnen ganz
ehrlich ich hätte mich wahrscheinlich
schon vor wochen selbst in die klapse
eingewiesen aber dann hat die ampel ja
zum glück dass kiffen legalisiert damit
komme ich gerade so durch den tag ich
hab vor sich ja doch noch ist es ja
nicht legal und das ist mir scheißegal
erst mache die idioten die impfzentren
nicht ohne uns vorher zu fragen und dann
sagt die politik auch noch sinngemäß
tierärzte einfach impfen und fresse
halten jetzt ist es auch machen und dann
würden sie auch mal statt golfplatz am
samstag platz zum leben zu machen es
gibt nichts
muss ich mir von dem laumann anhören
diesem bauern der aussieht als ob er
jeden tag auch spaß drei ferkel erwirkt
nur altes klischee natürlich ärzte
golfen ja kennt man ja dann war ich
damit das letzte mal auf dem golfplatz
gut was ich natürlich mache ich übe
während ich impfe das packen aber das
schadet ja nun kein
herzen wir radeln rödeln rödeln grünen
irgendwie wird das nicht gesehen schau
mal ich führe um diese uhrzeit noch
beratungsgespräche mit booster
interessenten die das sparen total
verunsichert hat hallo mein namen heißt
er ist da und ich bin eine verunsicherte
also glaub ich
wieder noch fräulein langsam wie schon
gesagt ich hätte da eine sehr schöne
dosis moderner für sie im angebot ich
würde ich es einfach bitten kurz den
linken arm frei zu machen weil ja wie
sie wahrscheinlich gesehen haben draußen
noch 3000 leute warten wir auch gm
führen wurden ja kann sein aber warten
sie bitte nicht so schnell einen moment
noch also ich hätte diesbezüglich noch
ein paar expertise fragen weil ich war
eben noch kurz im internet oh gott ja
und zwar wegen diesen modernen
würde das denn genau schlecht werden
weil das ist sehr unterschiedlich mit
dem verfallsdatum
ich habe da zum beispiel der panke mal
eine frikadelle gekauft und die war
eigentlich erst zwei wochen abgelaufen
aber ich hatte trotzdem fortschritte
nebenwirkung ich schwöre
schwedischen details gehen nur soviel es
war oben und unten
danke dass nämlich teilhaben lassen ich
kann ihnen versichern moderner ist ein
hervorragender impfstoff jaja hat das
mag ja auch alles stimmen aber ich sag
mal so nur weil etwas moderner heißt
muss es ja nicht automatisch ungern
sehen wir ganz ehrlich meine innere
stimme sagt wo von innen drin vor nicht
damit war die werbung sie belügt dich
der werbung liegt die andauernd ich sag
nur katzen würden whiskas kaufen
nein würden sie nicht den kampfnamen
backen geht an oh
ja aber
zurück zu dem thema tatsachen also
moderner deshalb schon internet gelesen
dass sind teilchen dieses bike proteine
und die sind voll gefährlich schwester
von ihrem freund weil der ist jeden
morgen proteine der macht mich fitness
und der folgende vierten body und der
sagt proteine niemals mit spikes essen
dance heißt auf französisch
stacheln und diese stacheln zu stören
sein erbgut das steht so im internet
mutig
oliver
möchten sie das ihren booster oder
möchten sie ein booster nicht denn meine
bitte ich kann nicht glauben dass ich
mich jetzt wirklich zu leben von oben
herab drängeln schulmedizin ja ich hab
mich erst letztens mit meinen nachbarn
unterhalten und von der heilpraktiker
erkennt einen schamanen und der meint
kämpfen ist sowieso quatsch weil der
körper dann muss die infektion busch
machen er verbietet sogar den kindern
fahrradhelme zu tragen weil mit deinen
intakten immunsystem ist ein verkehrs in
folge kein problem sagt er ja und
deswegen bin ich mir da nicht mehr so
sicher ob der booster für mich in frage
kommen ich hab noch nicht mal die erste
impfung biete ich habe ich noch gesagt
jeder fragt es geht zweig ja ich dachte
von handy umfahren
sehen sie was ich meine herr welke so
sieht das hier aus ich will nur noch
nach hause so der nächste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
martina
ihrig ja es ist nur hier wäre ich sogar
nachteile wie wir sind wirklich ein
komisches land nur drei tage bahnstreik
und alle kriegen direkt schnappatmung
aber wenn das pflegepersonal streikt
maximalen meldung auf seite 12 unter der
homestory über die drillinge von bushido
in dieser woche gab es zum beispiel
mehrere verdi streiks an uniklinik in
nordrhein-westfalen und womit mit recht
weil man die hilferufe dieser branche
seit der korona krise mehr oder weniger
ignoriert
es geht ja nicht nur darum dass ich
bessere arbeitsbedingungen haben möchte
es geht vor allen dingen darum dass ich
die patienten gut behandeln wir können
fünf minuten ist die lüge die man glaube
ich am häufigsten erzählt und die
versorgen patienten die am fließband und
dadurch fällt scheinbar auch niemand
mehr auf dass wir irgendwie aus dem
letzten loch reisen suchen ja das kann
sein wahrscheinlich haben wir das
pfeifen nicht gehört weil das klatschen
vom bakom zu laut war
immerhin will die ampel jetzt eine
milliarde für neue boni ausgeben was
toll ist wobei das pflegepersonal aber
vor allem wir haben es gehört über den
miesen personalschlüssel klagt und das
grundübel in deutschen krankenhäusern
war bekanntlich die einführung der
fallpauschale im jahr 2003 denn seitdem
müssen die profitabel sein ja ganz
tollem ist idee eingeführt unter gerd
schröder abgeschafft hoffentlich unter
olaf schmidt scholz man
herkommt einer von beiden soll zeit
abschaffen hier neues tolles handy game
für pflegekräfte ist super das erste
level niederlande wir sind doch einfach
bei denen ist eine pflegekraft für
gerade mal sieben patienten
verantwortlich lächerlich level 2
schweden schon härter acht patienten pro
pflegekraft aber da kann sie
zwischendurch noch pinkeln gehen luxus
aber dann boss level deutschland 13
patienten vorsicht achte auf die burnout
anzeige zu spät
und nach feierabend wird gestreikt
vorüber aber kein schwein berichtet weil
deutsche medien sich ausschließlich für
den babybauch von helene fischer
interessieren jetzt runterladen das
traurigste spieler aller zeiten angry
birds ja
macht wenig spaß
viele
viele unserer pflegekräfte sind nach all
den crooner monaten regelrecht
traumatisiert und ich sagen hut ab gut
ab für jeden der da morgens noch zur
arbeit kommt warum hört nie auf die
klagen der pflegeberufe warum jens spahn
zum beispiel jens spahn wir kommen schon
wieder auf ihnen hat vor zwei jahren
verdi und die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft beauftragt ein
konzept für eine neue
menschenwürdigere personalbemessung zu
erstellen haben die gemacht und dann ist
original nichts passiert warum hat der
ministerin solches gesetz bisher nicht
erlassen
das müsste ich nachreichen gewinnen
könnte später teilt das ministerium
schriftlich mit es wolle bis ende
2024 ein modernes personalbemessung
instrument für die krankenhauspflege
entwickeln cool schon 2024 da kommt das
ja genau pünktlich zur moment zehnter
corona welle
komisch warum fliegen denn so viel aus
diesem job es ist ein rätsel im letzten
jahr gab es noch 12.000 intensivbetten
mit beatmungsgerät jetzt nur noch 9000
wegen personalmangels manche kündigen
andere gar nicht mal wenige gehen auf
teilzeit aber wie viele genau schon weg
sind weiß niemand weil es kein
bundesweites register für das
pflegepersonal gibt warum auch immer
hier neu bei vox
ich habe den ganzen tag als liefer
sklave durch die stadt das geld ist ein
schlechter witz und ich habe faustgroße
hämorriden aber immer noch besser als
mein alter zopf im krankenhaus ich sage
tote tiere in einer großschlachterei und
stehen knietief in eingeweihten aber
hauptsache nie wieder klinik ich bin
nach weißrussland ausgewandert und
schupfte jetzt in einem uran bergwerk
wahrscheinlich werde ich keine 40 aber
meine work life balance ist so viel
besser als auf der intensivstation
das alles bei goodbye krankenhaus die
aussteiger
[Musik]
man kann es absolut verstehen
melde was diese woche sächsische
krankenhäuser bereiten sich schon auf
träsch vor das ist ein ethischer
albtraum für das ohnehin ausgelaugte
personal was tun wir den an auch darüber
sollten im skeptiker und verweigerer
vielleicht mal nachdenken menschen die
man in keinem fall über einen kamm
scheren darf das mir schon klar die aber
in bestimmten milieus eben doch häufiger
anzutreffen sind laut aktuellen studien
besteht ein deutlicher zusammenhang
zwischen afd wahlerfolg und
infektionszahlen es ist so je besser die
afg zahlen desto schlechter die
impfquote dazu nun ein paar kurze
anmerkung von friedemann weise
ratschläge in die fresse mit friedemann
weise
was ist da los die hälfte der
ungeimpften hat die afg gewählt und man
muss sagen die afg hat auch viel dafür
getan während hätte zum beispiel hat die
ungeimpften als freiheitshelden
bezeichnet ja freiheitshelden da dachte
man früher an gandhi oder martin luther
king aber in diese reihe gehört jetzt
auch ronny aus sömmerda weil er sich
nicht impfen lässt und das tut er nicht
für sich sondern für den erhalt des
deutschen volkes denn wir können nicht
ausschließen dass eine injektion wird
dieser gentherapie ich die
unfruchtbarkeit der nächsten generation
produziert stimmt das kann man nicht
ausschließen
außer man glaubt der sogenannten
wissenschaft aber dass ausgerechnet
röcke gegen die impfung ist wundert mich
wo doch gestern der thüringer landtag
seine immunität aufgehoben hat
verstehen sie immunität mir egal aber im
ernst gerade ein faschist wie herke
sollte doch das prinzip einer impfung
regelrecht feiern ungewollte
eindringlinge die unser system von innen
heraus zerstören wollen werden einfach
mit zwei gezielten schüssen in den
oberarm unschädlich gemacht ich frage
mich wirklich woher der mann seine
kompetenz in sachen impfen nimmt ich
sage euch als vierfacher familienvater
lasst euch nicht impfen es so stimmt
nichts beweist die die klinische
expertise besser als die zahl der kinder
sie merken lieber afd weder ich will da
auch nicht gehen ruhe du hast nur zwei
kinder wo war ich ja lieber auf die
villa falls sie die afg wegen ihrer
corona politik gewählt haben muss ich es
ihnen leider so hart sagen sie haben
sich verwählt gerade sie als patrioten
sollten doch wissen der lockdown der uns
jetzt nur wegen der im flocke droht
schadet der deutschen wirtschaft und der
deutschen kultur sie sollen feingeister
wie kino group alle an ihre wöchentliche
dosis goethe und schiller kommen wenn
die theater wieder schließen müssen und
kultur hat ja nicht beim theater auf was
ist mit der deutschen küche hier wird
bier wein und schnaps getrunken und hier
wird schweinefleisch gegessen dass die
schwarte kracht ja eben nicht beim
lockdown ist nämlich wieder alles dicht
was wir als land gerade liefern ist
einfach nur noch peinlich aus
deutschland kommen die wichtigsten
erfindungen der medizingeschichte das
heftpflaster eine deutsche erfindung
genau wie die röntgenstrahlung sogar die
homöopathie ist eine weltweite
erfolgsgeschichte aus deutschland und
die wirkt noch nicht mal und jetzt hat
ein deutsches ehepaar aus mainz den
impfstoff gegen krohne erfunden er ist
den siegeszug um die ganze welt
angetreten und ausgerechnet wir
deutschen haben so eine miese impfquote
das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein der
französische präsident hat die korona
krise schon letztes jahr als krieg
bezeichnet ein krieg der in der ganzen
welt bietet quasi ein weltkrieg und
deutschland ist so kurz davor schon
wieder zu verlieren also liebe die
schottin und patrioten krempelt die
ärmel hoch und lassen damit ihr auch bei
der nächsten wahl noch wählen könnt habe
dann hoffentlich was anderes schiff
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]